[MUSIC]
Let's talk about the sort
of perception of time.
Now, what the research shows us is that
perception of experienced time is largely
different by attention.
Time bothers us when we
pay attention to it.
And so the name of the game is
to give people distractions,
it makes time feel like
it went by quicker, okay?
So give your customers
something to do while waiting.
Compare an elevator ride.
Some companies use music, but
usually, they use irritating music.
But what if you play them the news or
some kind of interesting podcast?
And then it almost becomes something,
it's distracting and fun to be waiting.
The other thing to do to manage time
is give people a sense of progress.
Okay, the one thing we really
don't like is not knowing, right?
Not knowing when this
thing is going to end.
Actually, airlines used to be bad at this.
You had a boarding time, but it was
never kind of clear exactly when it was.
And now they've shifted to telling you
exactly when the boarding time is.
And they even have
a countdown telling you,
boarding is going to commence
in X amount of minutes.
The exact same amount of time where
you know kind of you have a sense of
progress versus you don't have a sense
of progress feels completely different.
And so Disney recognizes that it has
people waiting in lines for a ton of time.
And so what they do is they have these
kind of mileposts where they say,
this is how much time you have left to go,
to give you a sense of what's happening.
Because what we really don't like, because
we don't like to have an experience where
we don't have control, right?
So you want to give people
a sense of control.
What matters is not actual control, but
it's your sense of perceived control.
Do I feel like I'm controlling
the time that's passing?
Or is this something else controlling
it and I have no control over it?
Most of the time, customers
are engaging in these experiences and
they're not cynical.
When I go to Disney,
I know they're messing with my mind
with all the information about
the waiting time, but it still works.
You can have an objective time in
which something happened that's
very different than the subjective
time in which something happened.
So the question is, how do you manage
that subjective sense of elapsed time?
>> Understand how consumers experience and
rewire your approach to marketing.
Learn more about The Emerging CMO:
Strategic Marketing Leadership.
[MUSIC]